our series kindness 101 with Steve
Hartman that's when we share stories
built around kindness and character and
the people who've mastered those
qualities today's lesson is untact oh
important lesson yeah definitely need to
know more about tact myself Steve and
his kids teach us to think about
people's feelings when you're delivering
bad news like when you're telling
somebody their baby actually might not
be as cute as they think
good morning this is my daughter Meryl
hi and we're here to discuss something
very important for civil conversation
it's called tact and for a definition we
go over to my brother Emma at the
dictionary desk Emmett good morning
Merle tactics are being a keen sense of
what to say in a conversation when the
subject turns a little dicey especially
in a conversation that could potentially
hurt someone's feelings right it's like
when we talk about my hair now when I
look in the mirror I see brown I want to
think my hair is brown but you guys
always insist on contradicting me and
saying my hair is gray
uh that's because it is gray it really
couldn't be more gray it's like you have
some sort of hair dysmorphia even your
wife disagrees with you
obviously tact is something we're still
working on around here
which is why today I'm reaching deep
into the archives for a story I did back
when your brother George was born a
story that explores the delicate balance
between honesty and kindness known as
tact
we think she is actually the cutest baby
ever to be born people have said that to
us you know they say that to every baby
actually they were telling the truth
what is it that makes parents so
delusional I don't know we just feel
like she actually is that cute so
unabashedly biased I know what's cute I
know what's ugly that's cute is it not
long ago we ask parents to send in
pictures of both cute and ugly babies
nearly 2 000 people send in shots of
their supposedly adorable Offspring but
almost no one cop to having even an
average looking child that's why after
my son George was born I decided to find
out once and for all is my son cute or
not okay that is a cute baby look at his
eyes as I expected everyone said he was
cute I thought a big smile this is the
picture I showed people at first but
then as a control I started showing this
distorted version that baby is adorable
right oh come on look at that look at
the smile believe it or not everyone's
still gushed thank you over my little
monster oh he's so cute and so it went
no matter who I asked oh good lord or
how ugly I made the picture that's not
an insect no no that's a hairy mole
that's a hairy boy but it's still cute
though oh it sure is at the risk of a
lightning strike I then asked father
Kelly if it's a sin to tell parents
their baby is cute when you really don't
think it is that's not a lie all the
difference between a lie and what they
call a mental reservation well if that's
true then how do I know that you think
my child's cute
oh I see because he is
I was about to give up and that's when I
thought of Marlene Wallach what are you
looking for looking for honesty that's
what you got Marlene heads up Willamina
kids a child modeling agency I showed
her pictures of what George really looks
like and although At first she too
couldn't help but be diplomatic it's a
cute baby eventually I got it out of her
I'm just saying you're lying aren't you
it's okay I've been looking for somebody
to tell me the truth the truth is the
baby is very average
there you go how come nobody else would
tell me my baby's average looking but
now you hate me no I don't no I don't I
think you might
14 years have passed today George isn't
into the whole TV thing as much as his
younger siblings but he has graciously
agreed to join us now hello George hey
so George I didn't show you that story
for the longest time because I was kind
of worried how you'd take it and now I'm
wondering how did you take it pretty
well I mean I am not a virgin by any
stretch of the imagination did it hurt
your feelings to see that you were never
going to be a baby model
okay when you think it's especially
important to be tactful what sort of
situations when someone get a leader
pridefully asks you like do you like
this or do you think this is cool if
somebody's saying do you like this dress
I would choose politeness if someone
said do you like this dress I would say
no but provide a redeeming statement
such as maybe you could do such and such
with it like leave it in the closet yeah
like so sequins onto it
it
maybe the only thing we've settled here
is that cuteness is relative if the baby
is your relative
it's cute thanks for watching and don't
forget to stay kind
I'll love that I gotta have dinner with
the heart I'm telling you if we honestly
raffle off a ticket for dinner with the
hartmans and go for a lot of money no
doubt about it so when he went to the
church what was the response good Lord
good Lord and then the priest took the
glasses off just to gather himself he
was saying in his head I don't forgive
me he was like Lord give me the strength
you can't tell somebody that their baby
is ugly I'm just say that right if you
do pack an air conditioner in your
casket because
I can't say that I agree you gotta just
be polite you know what I mean yes I
think Honesty has limits that's right
there and we are all biased we all think
that our kids and babies look great no
Michelle you're the one that tells
people their baby's average and ugly I
didn't say average and ugly what would
you say interesting I know oh such a big
cheese okay such a
such a thing that makes sense he doesn't
have any hair oh I got you I see I have
but then I all my kids look like Wallace
Shawn when they were babies it's all
wrinkled up and small that was like my
daughter had huge all right